[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe
hey babe hey babe hey
[Music]
hey babe what's up babe how you doing
the la edition of hey babe at the
edition hotel
we're the new new edition this is it we
found a couch in l.a with pillows
this is it no one can tell where you are
this is
i came into the hotel with you uh uh
before i came up into your room
in the lobby right now uh he was there
20 minutes ago
wilma valderrama wilmer valderrama
from that 70s show handsome and what was
his show on mtv whoops what was the show
on mtv
what was this [ __ ] i never heard of a
show did it will develop
didn't will demaldorama have some show
on mtv wasn't it called like whoops or
was it yo mtv raps it was no that was
stop my friend yo mama
do you remember the show
well i'm actually talking about his
little brother yeah
yo-yo ma is a cellist jealous but
it's got a little bro everybody knows
that one jealous that's yo yo ma yeah yo
you jealous
why so do you challenge ellis
oh my god work stuff out yo yo ma
you cellist that's what i'm gonna say to
him next time i see him
look at this look at this this guy's in
the hotel lobby right now
yeah he just pulled up on on uh on one
of those hydraulic cars
they do your mama jokes no they don't
that's what the show is it's yo
you're [ __ ] me right now i swear to
god we're gonna watch it i don't care if
we get flagged
we'll put it on yo mama the sound board
cut out we lost 20 minutes
we we we recorded 20 minutes and the
board cut out and it's gone forever let
me just tell the cliff notes of the 20
minutes you guys will never hear just
put on pause
we pretty much discovered that uh i've
been saying wilmer valderrama and it's
will it's it's wilner no it's will murr
you've been saying wilder it's wilmer
we we also found out we kind of came to
conclusion that wilma
is a is a mostly dominican latina name
so wilma flintstone and the flintstones
in general are dominican
uh um um we also just uh i also told you
that
the guy who's giving me my cover test
who's my covert officer
on the set of backyard borrowers who's
been administering the culvert test for
the last three months
is in fact the actor i'm not saying he
looks like him i'm saying he physically
in the flesh the same dna
is the human being that played pugsley
adams in the movie adams family values
is my covet officer now and also my
entertainment lawyer
is jeff cohen aka chunk from the goonies
i'm surrounded by child actors
and um uh what what's what's what else
what what's one more thing i'm missing
from those 20 minutes um
one of the kids from the sandlot met me
backstage at one of my shows one time
because we were talking about childhood
actors
and uh within 30 seconds of me to me he
asked me how much i make he wanted all
my
financials he wanted all my financials
oh and
african-americans are the carry-ons of
the airline industry
because once you start carrying on you
never go back because yes it's just too
it's too too good because it's
convenient because
we we checked the bag we were in la and
i checked that now waited 45 minutes
uh you know and they put the little bag
on it says your preferential
yeah yeah it doesn't matter you come out
deadliest dead last
i feel like a failure every time i check
a bag and it kind of always sets me off
for a little bit of depression but
sometimes you got to do it
yeah yeah but i don't want to actually
actually no you know what i'm going to
take that back
i don't want to do it anymore i will go
away you could tell me i have to go away
for a year
i would put a carry on i would never
check it away i'll find i'll
continuously wash my clothes
i got the same shoes on the same but
i've been wearing the same pants and
shoes almost every episode of this
backyard bar war show
really thursday's 10 30 true tv that's
it no one ever really is
followed after 10 p.m right after an
episode of impractical jokers
thursdays 10 p.m on true tv
11 a.m hey babe hey babe thursdays are
for the babes
it's b day for the babies that's right
and
and i think true has even been saying
stuff like hey it's babe night
yes true tv has been tweeting hey it's
babe night and it's for the babes and
everything's for the baby
it's fun but be careful that's r.i.p
that is r.i.p and you will potentially
if you keep pushing it you will get a
call from jeff cohen aka trump from the
goodies
okay let's go this is yo mama will de
valderrama who's either in the basement
who's in the in the lobby though terrain
or on the pool it's like yo mama
oh mama yo mama no didn't we agree
like yo mama is so fat
i cannot believe what i am watching i
can't even see
him out of all people it seems like why
him i don't know why i watched every
episode i used to watch every episode of
this after school
oh it's like the first roast battles
this is so fake
i mean hold on pause this one second
pimpy this is hysterical they're clearly
in
on a set that makes it look like they're
in like a parking garage in a building
i guess they wanted to look a little
urban yeah and they're in this like
parking garage but it's clearly lit up
it's fake
and there's a crowd that kind of just
formed i wonder if this came out like
after eight mile
there's a car there's a crowd that
happened to form you could tell they're
all like
and hey what's up i'm coming to do stand
up chrisdcomedy.com we just put on sale
the dania improv in dania florida right
near the miami area
uh september 17th and 18th zany's
nashville
october 15th to 17th and philadelphia
pennsylvania
august 18 to the 21st we just opened up
some more seats um so go get those
tickets and then i got a bunch of other
dates
towards the end of the year
chrisdcomedy.com i like guys
and all right we're finally on the road
my dates have come out soon but i got
tour dates some of the guys and i
the impractical jokers tour um and i'll
just name some cities go to
thetenderloins.com for tickets
phoenix san diego sacramento minneapolis
green bay detroit milwaukee kansas city
sioux falls cincinnati cleveland
columbus
chicago uh boston syracuse newark
elmo new york new the new islanders
place
boise portland seattle tampa orlando
jacksonville nashville atlanta
niagara falls albany wilkes-barre uh
salt lake las vegas st louis oklahoma
city fort worth
costa mesa denver lincoln etc so all
we're coming to you and more dates will
be announced to tenderloins.com for
tickets
and even the jokes are like clearly like
stock jokes he said your mom is so
stupid because you tripped over a
cordless phone it's like that's
you didn't think of that that's coming
at it no you really throw throwing on yo
mama jokes
in a parking garage somewhere you're
getting a cap in your ass also the the
choice to host the yom yo yo mama
show of wilde valderrama is so
ridiculous
yeah why would you have him do it but
there was a time when he was in all the
papers like
hanging out the nightclubs and stuff
maybe he was just like the hot now guess
what year this started
2004 6 2006. wow so this is only 15
years ago how many seasons did it run yo
mama
let me see at least four by the way this
is a clip
of the best of mtv's yo mama and it led
off with your mama's so bad dumb she
tripped over a cordless phone
yeah well i know that's um yeah yo mama
i
i dude literally as soon as i saw him
as soon as i when i see wilde valderrama
which i just did 20 minutes ago
who is it world of alderaan yeah yep no
that's right right
wilmer who said vilda walderama
build a bill wow now it's really messing
me up now i would say ville de walderama
villa
rama remake mr dabalina mr bob dabalina
you know what song but delta funky homo
sapien
no mr dabalina mr bob davolina what's
his name the homo sapien
uh odell the funky homo sapien that's a
funny ass name yeah yeah he had a bunch
of hits
reduces i think he might even in the
gorillas
deal with the funky hulk
[Laughter]
funky pickle only two seasons of the
show by the way really
i wonder what happened jeez they ran out
no nothing against
wilmer but yeah wilma wilma used to you
know we used to
he this guy's a handsome fellow with a
lot of money and a nice track record and
he looked gorgeous downstairs he had on
three 400 pair of khakis he had on a
nice jacket he was with dylan mcdermott
uh the actor dylan mcdermott dylan
mcdermott one of those guys instantly
recognizable long career illustrious
even
uh famous talented i
always like either confuse him with
someone else or forget
what he's in i couldn't tell you one
thing dylan mcdermott's in but i've seen
him in everything
but i can't tell you what that one name
is like
i don't know why i have trouble
committing him and what he does to my
memory i clearly know who he is dylan
mcdermott recently is more famous for
that netflix show
that takes place like in the 60s but
it's about like a male
escort service and in the i will love
the show
but out of n i mean out of nowhere in
the first
episode there's just a scene with full
gay anal sex
like out of nowhere which people were
like whoa that's a lot it starts off
like that well it's like in the first
episode that's the tone
it says american horror story law and
order american horror story law and
order definitely more than that he plays
a mob boss
no he's been in there him and jerry
o'connell have been in everything and
it's almost impossible
if you can tell apart dylan mcdermott
and jerry o'connell you're like you must
be in mensa
there's no there's another guy like
daley mcdermott
dylan dolma dermot mulrooney tournament
mel rooney he used dylan mcdermott in
durham over like bill pax
now bill pullman now who's dermot now
which one's alive bill paxton and bill
pullman
who passed i don't know it's a sad story
either it's a sad story either way i
feel like
bill pullman passed away
bill pullman versus bill bill okay who
was in twitter
bill pullman or bill paxton jackson and
he was an independent no bill pullman
was in independence
day passed away then
the guy from twister yeah yeah with
helen hunt with a cow
yeah one of the best movies of all time
i haven't seen it since then
you've never seen twister more than once
since then yeah does it hold up
oh my god of course how often are you
watching twister i've
uh here's the thing i watched because i
watched twister
i what is this dylan mcdermott versus
durham dylan mcdermott or dermot
mulrooney this
so it's a is then it's a thing it's a
pop culture thing
okay i know which one's dylan mcdermott
how about that that german mulroney
that's not even who i was thought that
therma mo rooney was
it's probably really funny actually but
our fans did write in they wanted you to
address
uh how chris says uh umbilical cord
they say i said they were saying i said
biblical chord wrong
how'd you say it how did i say it in
biblical court is how you said it i
think you said
umbilical unbiblical you didn't say i'm
biblical
no they're saying in the show in the
show we were getting lit i was getting
lit up because they were saying that i
was saying it wrong but i don't know how
i was actually saying it
umbilical no um it's not um
is it um or m i thought it was
the umbilical chord here's one of my
guesses you
here's what i'm here's what i'm i'll try
i'll sound out the letters of what i'm
trying to say
umbilical chord u m b i
l i c a l umbilical umbilical
it's not that though but it's close what
is it then
oh you said it right how do you spell it
though u-n-b-i-l-i-c-a-l
you said it right right right spelled it
right so what was i saying last week
then
i have no idea i'm trashing him
umbilical i'm
i was saying i'm biblical i'm saying in
biblically in biblical court no that's
totally wrong that's wrong
speaking of biblical yeah you know
if they still i didn't have one in this
hotel because they always look yeah
do they put bibles in the hotels anymore
and who started that and why
i don't know where because it's
christian it's always the the
the holy bible so it's like
if if you're a jew jewish person or a
muslim person that's not my
one but a catholic or a christian i
suppose so like who
who who signed who inked the deal with
the hospitality industry saying that
we'll throw a bible in the right
in the right pocket of the in the right
nightstand
also who it's such an antiquated thing
at least i believe like who's arriving
to the hotel and being like
i'm gonna leave my bible at home because
i know there's a bible there so when i
and
when i get and when i check in i'm just
i'm just thumbing through corinthians
like nobody's biz
well i'll tell you this there's two
things one first thing is
my mother's very religious woman devout
catholic every time we go to hershey
pennsylvania we stay at this hotel the
bird in hand
we would go there all the time the bird
in hand bird in hand like a bird in hand
restaurant great buffet great breakfast
buffet
um but we would always stay there and
it's kind of like on like a you know
farm in lancaster pennsylvania but every
morning i'd wake up she'd be out in the
little rocking chair
reading passages of the bible so i that
so she would do that so that's that's
for customer who would do that first
time i've ever heard that in my entire
life
sound off in the comments shout out
bibles shout out bible shout out hotel
shout out convenience
yeah yeah shout out lancaster
pennsylvania yeah lancaster that's the
whole
amish langhorne sesame place
sesame place yeah which i got lost out
when i was a little kid
and they had to come over the
loudspeaker and tell me exactly where to
meet
really yeah because i i had my
grandfather was watching me and my
cousin and we had come down the slide
and we were supposed to go let's say to
the right where the exit was but we went
the other way and
then you know you start walking around
and then it gets comical but my
thing is is that maybe the vatican
is in cahoots with the hotel industry
maybe maybe the pope
owns a portion of hilton's or something
like that
so you guys want a fact about it yeah
a company named gideon international in
1899 three of their salesmen met in a
hotel room and the idea hit them to
distribute to hotels
and by 1908 that was their business oh
so they were selling them to the hotel
so it's been 125 years and we're still
doing it
well now it's being phased out but the
new thing hotels are doing is that
they're also facing
they're phasing out providing bibles and
they're phasing out the room number 420.
[Music]
what a stupid society there's also no
floor 13s in any hotel which is i mean
how ridiculous is that it is ridiculous
there's no 13th floor here in this hotel
will always go up to 13. but in most
hotels when they're oh
buildings when there is a 13 it's not on
there i rarely see a 13.
same with me i really really rarely see
it that's so interesting with the bible
thing that it's all business though it's
all marketing
but what about the 13 i mean who's the
guy that's like not my elevator company
yeah that's that's dangerous also the
people on 14 know they're on 13
right you have to i mean like what am i
an idiot
you're going to put me on 14. it's 13.
yeah it's a big cover-up i'd rather be
upfront with me don't put me on 14 and i
go there and there's all sorts of
hauntings so
stupid but are you a big superstitions
person no but like then again
but superstitions if you if you're it's
it's a weird thing because if you're
superstitious
and religious then the bible says
superstitions aren't real and don't
believe in them and if you are
superstitious you're like that's from
the devil
so you really technically can't be
religious and superstitious but so many
of my most superstitious friends and
family
are religious it's strange that's kind
of like a literally a riddle
chrissy riddles superstitious and
religious
shirt i look like the riddler right now
i'm a trendy regular i love your color
story today yeah
kunaflex results that is a nice uh
that's a really nice color on that top
the other day i swear to god i was uh
i was my girlfriend comes out and she
was like she was like oh what should i
wear to this thing and i
said i said this i said what about that
little number you had on uh
little number i said i could refer to an
alpha she had
add-on as a number little number little
number that you had on and i as i said
what about that little number i laughed
like pimp like i went
what did she say what is so freaking
hard i'm like who am i turning into a
little no
put on that little number little number
i've never said that in my life that's
like what they did not like the 1920s
well that's what i was talking she was
yesterday we were at the show yesterday
she goes um well if you're on stage or
whatever and then i go um
i go we got drinks and i didn't have
like any uh you know anything to tip and
cash was paying the card and i said i
said you got some scratch on you so i
could give
and then she said what did you just say
i said you got some scratch where i
could throw this bartender and
she was like what the scratch where did
scratch come from
scratch is a good word oh i like scratch
scott ol is what we just got off
yeah little shot
is that really what it's from escarole
and beans greens
green wow i never knew that yeah
you ready for scratch yeah uh it came
from the starting line of a race which
is scratched in the ground
but but how does that mean money i have
no i mean
maybe if you cross the line first and
one like a horse race or something you
want money you want
scratch let's see get some scratch i
don't know i don't
got all cheddar cheddar cabbage
oh actually it says for money uh 20th
century complete mystery no one
understands the context
wow okay thanks internet nothing showed
back here we could destroy this i mean
all right squarespace everybody you know
me i'm christy squarespace
sal's on vacation but you know he's
sally squarespace homeless pimp actually
used squarespace
to make our websites so we do
squarespace right pimpy we love it
all in one platform e-commerce domains
marketing tools
they got a bunch of stuff you build your
website with squarespace they make it
very easy very simple
a freaking dum-dum can use squarespace
it's the best
and we're going to give you we're going
to give you guys a nice nice nice
discount here at hey babe all you got to
do
is go to squarespace.com hey babe
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch use the offer code hey babe
and you're going to save 10
off your first purchase or of a website
domain so they don't even dude
they're not even making you do it
they're saying dude go to
squarespace.com
heybay for the free trial and if you
like it and you're ready to launch
use the promo code hey babe you get 10
off build your website
send us your websites we'll probably
think it's viruses and not open them
but maybe we will and maybe it'll be a
virus and maybe it won't but to be
honest with you if i'm going to get a
virus i want to get one from squarespace
i have aids
upstart you guys ready for a little
upstart if you're carrying a credit
balance each month which i know a lot of
us are which i know i am
it can feel like you're in a
never-ending cycle of debt
which debt it was always such a hard
word debt because it's d-e-b-t
so it's depth but it's really debt the b
is silent which is
some things are stupid in the american
language but what's also even stupider
or more stupid i don't know
is carrying debt and upstart's gonna
help you not carry that debt it's the
fast and easy way to pay off your debt
with a personal loan all online so i
used to have to go to the guys on the
street corner and get my loans paid for
an all cash
and then they threatened to break my
legs and kill my family if i didn't give
if i didn't give them their money back
with some juice on top of it
but now i don't because of upstart dude
upstart has genuinely saved my life
because i'm a degenerate piece of
garbage and i'm always in debt
and now because of upstart my legs won't
get broken by the gambino crime family
so here's how you can get a nice
discount with upstart go to upstart.com
hey babe that's upstart.com
hey babe okay do not forget to let them
know that we sent you with that url
upstart.com hey babe loan amounts will
be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application i
legally have to say that because if i
don't say that then the us government
will come after me
and break my legs financially maybe not
physically
but to be honest with you if it was
between the us government coming after
me and the gambino crime family i picked
the gambino crime family
because i can still be funny with a limp
but if you take all my money away and i
got to go back to driving a toyota i'm
screwed so go to upstart.com
hey babe babe i gotta be honest i've
been in la now
a lot over the last few months i just
la is all about their love detoxing and
cleansing
and i think that that's what i'd like to
do
for now temporarily with the cities i'd
like to detox
and cleanse from it i got i would say
borderline annihilated drunk last night
and you didn't know
that i was drunk which is a little scary
to me because i was i couldn't drive
homeless people to drive the car home i
didn't i could not get behind the wheel
but i was but i think i got so true i
don't really see you drunk like that
it's very rare well i'll tell you what
happens a lot of times people get they
go drunk they close the scene i went
got back to the hotel last night got
drunk was in bed ready to go to bed had
just eaten keto had felt great i ordered
domino's banana pepper pizza
cheesy bread and a diet dr pepper and i
woke up this morning
you know really feeling bad about myself
and then finished the last two slices of
pizza that i
saved from the night before cause i was
like let me not be terrible
how did you okay this is the thing you
ordered it was you were in bed already
yeah and now i'm sitting like this this
is happening i'm sitting like this
and i just feel my back my fat crumpling
together oh yeah
which i i didn't feel that two weeks ago
yeah yeah now i feel crumpling together
it's like a five pound variant
why do why do you start to feel your bat
your back fat crumpling
in literally five pound variance yeah
right i know that's where
that's where we live we yeah yeah well
you you already in bed then you had to
call then you had to stay awake
well i was in bed waiting for it to come
i was did you eat it in bed
yes i had two beds i ate it on the bed i
wasn't using
and i actually have it still on unless
the cleaning people came and cleaned it
up
those boxes are still on that bed i
literally sounded like a weird flex
yeah i gotta keep them two beds i eat in
one bed i sleep in the other
yeah i literally i would i fell as after
i ordered it i fell asleep and then was
awoken by the delivery guy
calling me to say food in lobby
i was also one floor above you yeah yeah
pimp was one floor above me you had no
idea the debauchery but hey
it's not worse than joe derosa joe
derosa called me yesterday listen to
this folks
joe joe derosa the taste buds podcast
yeah joe derose jojo
well i'm wearing look he's probably
sleeping joe derosa called me this
morning
and said how was your night last night i
said well i you know ate there's a box
of domino's pizza in the bed next to me
i you know i had sex with it
so i was like it's kind of a weird night
i feel guilty so he was like
ain't worse than me he said i was
hanging out
at the stand comedy club chilling with
my friends he goes and then
my other friend owns a bar he was like
in the bar she opened it up for us at
like 2am or 3am he said and then we were
drinking there was six o'clock in the
morning and i fell asleep in a booth
in the bar and he was calling me which
was 10 45
a.m new york time calling me in his walk
home from the bar
that he was sleeping to his to his uh uh
apartment in new york and he was had me
on he put me on hold for a second so he
could order
burger king delivery to his apartment
she was like
joe is this a call for help yeah i was
like
i was like joe it's you're what are you
doing i mean he should be out here in la
with us
he should have been the first guest on
hay bay but instead he's sleeping in
boots and bars eating whoppers
that's bad when you fall asleep in a in
a business you ever fallen asleep
inside yeah i have no but something like
that you fall in love because you used
to run a bar you ever fall asleep in the
bar you used to own
yeah yeah like fully in the ball you're
asleep you woke up in the morning there
oh um no i mean i stayed through the
night
like partying right that's one thing but
i'm talking about you fully
he went to bed for the night in the
booth i went to bed and they got me up
and took
one time i got so drunk when the
steelers uh made this uh super bowl
uh everybody wanted to buy me shots i'm
a steelers fan and i was doing them and
then i said danielle steele
what's that danielle steele yeah
danielle yeah big steel fans danielle
steelers
yeah she's a real she's an author right
yes yeah
oh is that have you ever read a romantic
novel
have you ever read one where they have
like actual like they describe like
intimate romance like in it like like
that like the ones that like women read
and that's their like like 50 shades of
grey
well i would isn't that like something
really progressive remember like the
ones that like to get like fabio on the
cover like those like a romeo and juliet
like a romance novel like a
classic romance novel no but it's
but you've ever seen like that like the
excerpts yeah of like the of the pros of
like the of the stories where they're
just like
he pressed his you know hand firmly
against her buttocks
yeah but it's supposed to be like sexy
yeah once you say buttocks to me i'm out
yeah you know yeah i don't like when
people do that
you haven't you ever you ever been
around someone who doesn't really know
how to speak
yeah in a way that is called for when
that time is
yeah people that that let's just avoid
it
[Laughter]
you can see that story on the patreon do
you know
do you know what my dad says all the
time that is just like i mean it's just
a simple thing
but like if you were saying if you were
like in a
hotel or a restaurant and you had to and
you had to pee
and you didn't know where the room what
would you say to a worker there what
would you say would you say where is the
oh excuse me
um can you direct me to the restroom to
the restroom my dad always says can you
direct me to the men's room
he always just says the men's room i
thought you were gonna say he says can
you tell me
show me where the toilet is which is a
hundred times worse no
he always just says do you have a men's
room but i always just thought it was
weird
i don't know i just he's the only person
that says can t where's the men's room
do you have a men's room a men's room a
men's room i would just say
i'm kids you should say bathroom
bathroom or restroom yeah yeah so you
don't think there's a problem with
saying where's the men's room
no i thought you were going to say
toilet or [ __ ] or something like that
it's not as common to ask for where's
the mansion
they just call it the toilet you have a
toilet it's on the signs it's on
everything they just say
where's the toilet which is gross they
called like i guess the room itself
becomes the toilet
but they're really just calling it the
toilet i know i i call it the washroom
in england
the washroom has the toilet in it well
the washroom i i don't mind yeah but
you're not washing you're not but it
doesn't make sense to me because
i'm going to the washroom what do i want
yeah but you tell me there's a washroom
if i've never been to england actually
go wash him i said he's going to go in
there and take a bath
water cloth but if if i don't know
anything and you say you're going into
this public stall
and i'm going into your washroom like
what are you going to wash yourself with
the toilet water
hippo yeah right water water closet is
like a
water closet it's pretty innocuous the
water closet but again i don't
understand what that means either
what's a water closet but i would be
embarrassed embarrassed as hell to go
downstairs be like hey
i don't think i could do it go down says
can you tell me where the toilet where's
the toilet
i see to run too crude but do you say do
you say like if you have to go
like like you know in public whatever
would you say
like to the people would you say i got
to go pay or would you say i just got to
go to the bathroom
i always if i have to pee if i say to
you i have to go to the bathrooms
because i have to go take a poop but if
i say i gotta go pee it's because i'm so
i'm going i'm talking to you i would
just say the real thing but i would
never just address out loud like i had
to take a peek
you know what i say a lot now a lot now
i guess just because you know the kids i
i'll say like in public to like a
meeting with like agents like let me go
pee pee
i said let me go people but i'm being
dead seriously let me go pee pee yeah
i'll go let me go to peepee deepsea
when we uh when we sold at the
television show in practical jokers
we went out we filmed on our own like
four or five little bits on our cell
phones
and one of the bits they weren't this
was the only one that was like toilet
humor
but we would just we walked into
businesses and said excuse me do you
know where the bathroom is and they'd be
like all right and we just have to say
oh cause i got to do a peep so i got to
do poops
right and uh it was it was like 10 years
ago it was the first we were laughing at
that we almost just did a video of it
just for the internet and we did it and
we couldn't say it
serious without laughing in people's
faces right and so it became funny and
so
we put it in the tape and it was because
of that one because the other ones we
didn't laugh
was because of that bit especially me i
was like oh
oh because i just i gotta go and i
couldn't get it out and i would start
laughing
we left it in and they really loved that
and that's when we were like
oh we should just leave in us laughing
and not being able to do it
sure that's the whole show definitely it
came from that
bit we call peeps and poops peeps and
poops
that because because they think people
think that don't watch the show think
this [ __ ] the whole show is just like
that silly kind of stuff but it's like
so
so different but that was one i couldn't
say it i could not say it to these
people at these retail stores you
couldn't say peeps or poops or either
either i just
i couldn't i was like because i gotta
and i just couldn't say it and then
joe went and he's just like right in the
face he's like yeah i gotta take a poops
wicked poops right in their face right
just like a little smirk maybe
we're like oh we should just leave it in
if we if we mess up or if we laugh or
whatever
yeah yeah i i you know i don't know like
you do you go downstairs right now
welcome to the front desk there's
probably a uh will the vulnerable high
or yeah like
or even if it's worse even if it's like
a a woman down there and you go
excuse me i have to take a poops do you
know where the bathroom is i have to
take up poops
i think if like you were making me do it
like i would be mortified i i couldn't
do it now even at all
if you like made me do it and you said i
can have any alliteration of it i would
probably just for me i'd go
i i gotta go take a poopy-doopy that's
what i would say just to like make it
really cute
no you can't do that though you're
getting out of it then
poopy doopy's funny too but then it's
like you are recognizing that you're
being silly
and calling it out but if you just tell
the girl downstairs
uh do you know where the bathroom is and
then the funny part is she says right
over there and then
then you go thank you because i have to
do poops
and then just look at her just look at
her and walk away i would love it we're
done with this
we go downstairs you have a lav mic yeah
i love we finishes we throw a lava on
you go right downstairs and we just he
just stands on the side and you do it
and we put it up should we do that
[Laughter]
but you can't smile you got to just be
like thank you
because i have to do poops now and it
has to be a woman i have to do poops
yeah
okay you think you could do it without
laughing oh my god
you get nervous yeah i don't know right
this is what
lives that's not fun everyone thinks
it's fun
what's the most nervous you've been for
one of these oh so nervous
like that's just the line now though you
don't understand that's nothing that's
embarrassing but when they when you say
something that's edgy
because we know that you don't we would
never say that you don't want to say it
to any i mean it's like i i don't i
don't explain it to you but it's like
it's uh the stakes are high now anxiety
yeah
yeah let me ask you this because because
in the 20 minutes that were cut out
another thing that we forgot to say
uh also is that we found out that in
some cultures
in american culture you need to look me
in the eye when i shake your hand in the
japanese culture
you do not look you do not look me in
the eye it's very disrespectful to look
me in the eye when you're shaking my
hand
what is that about we found out that it
was in many many cultures many many
cultures
which doesn't make any sense so it's
disrespectful to look in the eye
when you're saying hello and when you're
speaking to the person susan that means
when do you look at them so my question
though
is is if you make me do this bit this
poopy doopy bit
just poop it i gotta take a poopy i
gotta do
what if the worker down there is
japanese do i look them in the eye when
i say that or do what
no you look you got to make full eye
contact but that's disrespectful in
their culture
straight in yeah but i think that here
at the hotel they expect people to look
at them got it
okay okay well if i'm saying hello to
you and i'm like hey how you doing how's
everything good how's your life kids
good good we're going to
all right everything good you've been
over here you go real okay all right
take it easy
and then i walk away when am i looking
at you it's disrespectful to look at you
i think that in the asian culture they
have to give you the okay they have to
say something some type of signal that
says you can look at me now yeah but
but let's say let's say the both of us
that goes for though
so you're not looking at me i'm not
looking at you and then one of us has to
tell the other person you can look at me
now
what if i tell you to look at me now and
you're like fine but you can't look at
me yet look at me
i know i kind of think about it can we
like pull up maybe some like japanese
podcasts that are just like us
like are they looking at each other in
the eye is that maybe this is a formal
practice like if you don't know the
person
or maybe if it's if it's a person of
authority like a you know an officer
someone in a position of authority at a
company or i don't know whatever
i don't know because these cultures are
so weird where it's like
now we are different than ours where
it's like you can't look him in the eye
but then in other call also too in
america if you're eating we have
something
this is this is how to understand
japanese culture eye contact in japan
hi it's it's santi radio okay so uh
today's topic is eye contact in japan
yeah with the japanese people javier
spelled japan wrong
spell don't look at you directly he
didn't abbreviate any other world
tonight also like just put the a you're
watching this video a couple more
letters
it's not like an insane didn't say that
much like i was in a rush how you should
do when you talk to japanese people what
should you expect
all right so uh first of all let me show
you one comment i got from my subscriber
is that a uniqlo jacket you think mary
rose
uh here is the topic that you definitely
want to talk about why japanese guys
don't look at you when you talk to them
they either
look to another direction or look to
their feet while talking to you
in my country it is it means that
they're not interested
in talking to you they're lying or
they're not sincere yeah one can you
just
i mean i want to look away and just from
disgust yeah just i'm like i'm like you
need to
is it also in japanese cultures going on
and on and on i'm missing the point
here's something in my culture it is
very disrespectful to nail a point
yeah to get to the point quickly it's
very disrespectful i like the freeze
frame on his face too
here's something interesting i just
looked up while you were talking about
pooping um what do you think the proper
the best etiquette is there's two
schools of thought being argued here
one is like standing up squatting
slightly
and then the other one is sitting with
your knees higher than your hips
leaning forward with your elbows on your
knees for how to do a poopy doobie no
the most efficient poops
i think maybe squatty potty way right
yeah that's the way cause that's like
that's what i keep hearing about
standing up standing well they're saying
if you stand and squat
slightly that you're the lane of traffic
is just a straight shot okay well
i've never done anything but just sit
down yeah
well that's the thing too like you know
like my daughter is
she's three weeks old and you know she's
strange to poop and the doctor was like
yeah because
the doctor pediatrician posed a question
to me this was last week
i say i see you know she's always
trained to poop she goes well have you
ever have you ever laid down on your
back and tried to poop
i said no she said well that's what
she's doing she said you have all the
gravity on your side she can't sit up
she has no body control so she's trying
to push out a poop
without the without the assistance of
gravity at all you strain that
she's like go home she's like she's like
think if you want to put yourself in
your door to shoot she
said to me and jazz she's like go lay on
lay on the floor tonight and see if you
can push your poop out and you'll see
it's very difficult
but she's like you don't understand that
yeah i never thought of that either you
think you could do it
i don't think i could do it
[ __ ] just standing straight you know
what i mean just like stand straight up
just straight fully up yeah that'll work
right
you just it just will drop out i that's
kind of funny like if you're on the go
yeah you just go and do it patreon
imagine like everything existed in our
world except clothes
and wow wow and so like and and and then
and then like if
like people just went to the restroom on
the go like they didn't break stride
[Laughter]
like just when they had to go they go
like they're walking
yeah they're out they're standing and
talking
it is kind of one of those things where
it's like what
is i understand i understand diapers are
messy
but what is really what are the major
negatives of having an adult diaper like
if
they can make diapers that like it
contains it in a
place it the smell will never come out
no other than the mess like but you can
just
there's got to be some what you say
other than the mess but the mess is like
the only thing but if it saves
i guess yeah i mean homes would be cheap
but bathrooms are a ton of money
that's where people plunk down a lot of
the money money rights and bathrooms
brand new bathroom yeah yeah i guess
i don't know i mean i couldn't i
couldn't do it i mean if i you know
obviously there's people that have to do
it
yeah they got no choice have to do it
now i just pulled up a fact that says
within the next five years adult diaper
sales will
surpass baby diaper sales it says like
by nearly double
now why why is that i don't know
that's that doesn't sound right i mean
there's yeah why is that there's
a baby's coming in every second yeah why
would the maybe because they're elderly
wait we're multiplying at a rate quicker
than we did x
variables yes right like like there are
way more young people
than there are older people i believe
yes but older people are living
so long uh okay cause i was gonna say
isn't that gonna catch up to the point
where like
says 25 million americans wear diapers
every day
is that including babies uh this is
saying
uh adults is that is that because older
people are living
longer i guess so wow
it's one of those things that's
interesting too because
i yeah well i guess maybe are they only
are they saying that some toddlers are
not wearing diapers anymore is that like
a diaper
alternative because i always because my
kid's always in diapers for patreon
content would you wear a diaper and
uh 100 and just go a thousand percent
i'd do it to the bathroom
yeah i would do that for patreon
i would do that for the patreon when we
make it which is coming soon i swear to
god it's coming soon
you would go to the bathroom in an adult
diaper
that's a patreon for the patreon i'd do
this for y'all
you really i would do this for the babes
wait a minute would you do a show
and on stage break in the diaper for the
highest level tier of the patreon yes
what would that cost what level tier i
mean what are we gonna do tears wise
we're gonna do five ten twenty fives
i mean i i think it's gonna be a five
dollar level and then just a five
thousand dollar level
yeah for five g's i'll do it yeah yeah
uh how weird would that feel i had to
piss myself i told you that on the show
why no did you tell on the ship did you
tell us that on hey babe
i think i might have did you tell that
mike do you remember
no i don't remember this i think i did
they they fed me it was in the afternoon
i had to go into an escape room
it was my punishment with like six
people i never met before and
the idea was that as soon as the escape
room started the door locks for one hour
and as soon as the door locked they
wanted me to lit for real piss my pants
and then be locked in the room with six
strangers for one hour after that
so you had to immediately piss your
pants though you need
we got a nice new sponsor amazon music
as soon as jeff bezos got back from
riding his penis into outer space
he landed he contacted the people at hey
babe and he said i want
hey babe listeners to get trials of
amazon music
to uh you binge worthy podcast music
whatever you want they have 10 million
free podcast episodes to listen to 10
million freebies to listen to
i'm telling you there's no credit card
or subscription required you can even go
hands-free with alexa
okay so you want to you want to be you
don't even you don't even need to use
your hands
if you're if you're handless if you're
out there with just nubs
listening to hey babe you can literally
download amazon music and be a part of
this
all you have to do what do they have to
do pimpy all you have to do
is go to amazon.com
hey babe that's amazon.com
hey babe to stream thousands of music
stations and over
10 million podcast episodes for
free okay it's free just go to
amazon.com
hey babe start your free trial it's the
best thing to do
you're gonna love it as much as i do i
mean what are you people waiting for
amazon.com hey babe
every other every other place can suck
it amazon.com hey babe
butcherbox listen butcherbox it's one of
those places they've been sending me
stuff
and i got to be honest with you i'm
obsessed with it the quality meats they
even got v
uh vegetarian butcher boxes because jazz
doesn't eat meat um except last night
um because she you know she's still you
know
she's she's recovered cut that part out
um
i'm just kidding um listen a butcher box
what it is is is it's 100 grass-fed and
finished beef
free-range organic chicken you mainly
raised pork wild caught lobster tails
wild caught alaskan salmon you know how
hard it is to catch an alaskan salmon
and butcher boxer catch them in the wild
and sugar nitrate free bacon dude
sugar nitrate free bacon no bacon
no sugar in my bacon you if you want to
put a little bit of sugar on the bacon
you can
butcher box can't stop you but it's come
in packaged with no sugar and nitrates
which is dope
now butcher box wants to celebrate you
this summer that's what they want to do
so right now butcher box is offering new
members two
free lobster tails dude i mean why would
you not attempt to why would you not do
this
they're giving you free lobster tails
and free rib eyes in your first
box this do you know how much money that
is that they're giving away to you free
ribeyes and lobster tails these people
are insane
and that's why i love them if you go to
butcherbox.com
hey babe you'll get free lobster tails
and rib eyes in your first box
all you got to do you can only get this
special deal by the way
i oh i'm sorry i left that part out you
can only get the free lobster tails
and the free rib eyes if you go to
butcherbox.com
hey babe that's what you get you get two
five-ounce lobster tails and two
10-ounce rib-eyes
free in your first box if you go to
butcherbox.com
hey babe so you got to put in the promo
code hey babe you can get free lobster
tails
free ribeyes and why don't you invite me
sal and joe derosa and homeless pimp
over for dinner
if you got free lobster tails and free
ribeyes you [ __ ]
butcherbox.com hey babe and then i was
nervous because i had to
be able to piss on call which and you
you piss once a week i piss once a week
truly no truly how many times have you
you've been
it's it's 302 in the afternoon how
how many times have you urinated today
if at all i did urinate once today
because i took a shower and i like to
urinate before i go into the shower
fun fact about myself yeah uh other than
that i probably won't urinate again
you don't urinate in the shower i'm not
saying i haven't in my life but i oh if
i have to go and i'm in the shower
i'll hit the drain if i have to i i
don't think there's a shower i've taken
where i haven't urinated in the shower
oh so that's just your that's how you do
it i urinate why not just
turn on the water urinating the bowl
because i only feel the urge to urinate
when the water starts to hit my naked
body
my dad says urinate a lot too but not as
a joke
no he'll say like i gotta urinate i
swear to god
yeah he says mendrum and urinate that's
the other word i was thinking it was
like my dad says urinate speaking
urination
you know japanese toilets there's
toilets in japan right now where you
urinate in them
and it will send your medical records to
the doctor
i don't know if we've talked about that
on hay baby before oh i think i have
heard it yeah
it literally sends an email to your
doctor
that says what's going on you're in high
uric acid do you have gallstones like
whatever it is
that's unbelievable unbelievable you
piss in the toilet
and it emails your doctor they're called
smart toilets wow yup
yup that's i'm i'm out making that up
right yeah i'm seeing a bunch of them
yeah you're smart
and they're only in the us uh they're
only in japan you could get them in the
u.s
i'm sure you could get them here but it
looks like they're like 10 grand
you want to do it i mean the patreon i
mean i mean if it we could we can do a
gofundme
to buy a smart to buy a smart toilet and
then every guest we have
every single guest we'd have we'd have
to check that we'd have to check that
you're on yeah we can
we don't care if you're vaccinated or
not we need to check your urine you're
you're in check it'll get emailed to
whomever wants to be the hay babe
resident physician yeah we're going to
need a hey
president we need we need if we're going
to staff this thing
we need somebody from every field we
need a resident position
we need a hey babe uh uh uh person to
run the general store
we need a hey babe um mail person we
need a hey babe
uh accountant uh what we have hey baby
accountant
who else do we need how funny would it
be no joke though cause we were talking
about making a build down a little
studio what have you yeah
but if we go fund me a smart toilet
i have it installed in the ha in the
house in the studio
and then any or in the next studio in
the house and any guests we have
we take the urine sample and we deliver
it to the doctor
and then and then we give that we read
the results
on the on the next no matter who the
guest is we read the urine sample
results yeah and we on the next
on the next we start every and every
single hey babe episode starts with our
song that we have
yes followed immediately by the urine
results of the previous guests
yeah that's what i do what happens and
we keep them on file and every time they
come back we check
them on file yeah i mean what if we help
someone what do we save someone's life
oh yeah what if we like you know say you
got oh you got you gotta be careful you
got a high count
well that that i never did when i was a
physical therapist i was giving the lady
a neck massage
like because she was like had neck pain
whatever and i was doing and i was
literally i must have been a physical
therapist for a week
maybe two weeks and i was giving her a
back of a neck massage and there's it's
called an occipital release under here
you have
it's called the occipital bone part of
your skull and you put your fingers
under
and you do like a release and for people
have like tension headaches in the back
if you just like subtly just like
through like you know like
tension and traction just like release
like pull on the little bones of their
back over
the back of their head you know they
laid down i was doing it and i was doing
it and i said um
i said uh uh you know you have a bump in
the back here
in the back of your head here and she
was like really i said yeah because i
was doing the except release i said you
should really get that checked out
bumps on the occipital bone are very
rare i said so you should you know
really check that out she goes yeah i'm
sure it's nothing must be an ingrown
hair
i should maybe i said i'm just letting
you know um but
there was like an urge inside of me to
like one more time say to her without
again being a two weekend
therapist which is like a little like
you know i what the hell do i know i'm
not right i don't know anything i was
like i just don't feel like you just
just go look at it like i was like hey
like joking around like promise me
you'll look at that she goes yeah
so then she doesn't come back for her
next appointment not the next point next
supporter and finally asks
my head guy what happened or he goes oh
she had to get brain surgery she has a
she had
found that she had a brain tumor i swear
i was like wow and then she
finally came back but i wasn't a
therapist there anymore and she had
sent word to my boss like hey tell that
physical therapist kid he saved my life
wow
yeah yeah so so you save someone's life
supposedly yeah because they had a brain
tumor i don't know if she might be dead
now
from something else or anything yeah
she may have died enough in a duck
hunting actually walked across the
street and been hit by an occipital bomb
oh yeah yeah dude she
so that that's the one and only time i
saved someone's life i saved a kid from
drowning once
at the pool area in our in our apartment
complex as kids
right i just saw him the pool was
crowded everyone was hanging around job
it was very active
and he just walked into a part that was
deeper than he could
swim i just saw him going like this but
his head was under and i just saw him
going like this
wow and i was like look at that i was
young i was like a kid myself i was
maybe a few years older than him
and i'm just looking at him and i'm
looking at him and
he's just like he can't
move swim get up he was just like going
like that with his arms and i
was like this looks good so i swam over
to him and i looked i went under and i
looked at him and i picked him up and he
was
literally like nearly passed out
and really yeah and i called and the
lifeguard jumped in and every all the
parents came over he picked them they
put him on a thing
and they were doing his stomach and he
started spitting out all the water and
everything
now now what year was that like 80s 90s
uh my guess uh it was probably
mid to late 80s because i would imagine
in the late 80s like that
probably at just a different time nobody
even called 9-1-1 the pool probably just
stayed open
it just the kid was back in the pool in
10 minutes nobody called 9-1-1 it was
just that kid literally might have been
back in the ride he was scored the pair
everyone was shook
for sure but you know he toweled down
and after
you know like later on he was back in
the pool i think yeah because nowadays
like
it was like he would have he would have
drowned like
in a pool with his parents probably
standing right next to him yeah they
were like
i mean it was adults ever i mean i was i
was next to him so with so many other
people
it was just so like busy that no one
really like noticed that he was in there
flailing yeah that drowning stuff it's
so because
have you ever given mouth-to-mouth to
anyone if i ever given mouth-to-mouth
uh no no but in physical therapy school
you had to learn how to do it so i did
have to
do practice mouth-to-mouth i wanted to
be a person cpr
and all that stuff and holly because the
last thing i ever want to do is be in a
position where
if i would have known that it would have
helped someone especially like a loved
one know it
and i don't know it so i want to do that
yeah but you don't know cpr and you
saved chance palmitary's life from
choking on the sandwich
he said i did it so poorly he's hired
someone to teach me so maybe we'll all
do it and film it
i would do that we were gonna have
someone come to the house a service yeah
because during covert i was like let me
let me better myself
yeah god forbid yeah i know oh my god
yeah yeah
you do it on the dummy but then it's my
friend was like oh i just took my whole
course online
and i was like but there's no one
there's no interaction you have to
physically practice right now but they
just tell you what to do
and i was like i don't know if i think
that's i took my real estate course
online
and i was a real real estate agent for
years i have no idea
really no i don't know anything and you
were a licensed realtor yeah yeah yeah
dude i told you freaking the guy who
played pugsley in the adams family took
a covid
swab testing online and to give me the
covet swamp for the last three and a
half months and then tells me out of
nowhere he's [ __ ] puggsy from the
adams family
i can't believe he gave me the kova test
and then an hour later
an hour later our trailer broke down the
air conditioning shut off and then he
treated the generator yeah he kept and
that's how we found
out because he came in the air this year
broke on in my trailer and i said it was
relatively hot i said hey
like you know texted the show and i said
can somebody send something to fix the
air conditioner
and jimmy showed up i was like oh no i
don't need a cover test
i was like somewhere around my coffee
test he goes no i'm here to fix the air
conditioner
i said excuse me he's like i'm union and
i'm covered
dude he's uh yeah man it's just so it's
just uh
in this town in los angeles you just
don't know
you just don't know who everybody's in
the industry
everybody's in the street you know it's
another fun fact we learned yesterday
chatsworth used to be the porn capital
of the world
right over here in the valley we're not
saying far from there then california
made a condom
rule where when you shoot porn in
california that they ha
you have to be wearing a condom so they
moved all the porn
to las vegas and chatsworth whose
economy was built up on renting out
their homes
for the porn industry is now turning
into disarray
because california you know want to make
everyone wear condoms so we found that
there's actually
they're trying to bring condomless porn
back to chatsworth so if you guys
want to go to um our website
uh hey babe.com do we even have
heybabe.com no
no press.com nopresh.com or no email us
heybaypodcastgmail.com
and figure out ways on how we can help
get condomless sex back to chatsworth
california
me and sal have talked about it off air
that we'd like to be advocates
for that is that just the industry or
everyone in chatsworth
yeah i mean first of all if you you know
listen we all like porn if you're
wearing a condom in porn
i'm out oh yeah you're not going to
watch that i don't want to watch that
i don't want to watch porn with a condom
yeah i don't want to do that i want i
need it to be condomless
i was watching actually porn the other
day because obviously i've been no this
is a crazy thing
i've been in i'm in the same at the
garland hotel it gets lonely i've been
there a week and a half
i was watching fair amount of porn i was
watching it the other day
like on my stay this trip in the garland
and i kept saying like what
the i i am positive i am positive
the actor who was in this porn who was
named i don't know was on pornhub
pornhub.com shout out to mcdermott promo
code hey babe
daryl rooney dormer mulrooney was having
sex with this woman and he had
genital warts he had warts all over his
penis oh
and i was like that's interesting i
don't know if i know i don't know if i
could recognize that they had warts he
had warts on his penis
watching you know doing pointing at more
turn his penis david's about to have
time and i might have i might have said
it on hey baby so please stop me if i
did
but then i ended up stop
[Laughter]
no time no no i um no did i take my time
and stop me again
no no no really um that i i found myself
in a famous porn producer's home
what yeah and he wasn't home how did
that happen
the first time i ever the first time i
ever visited los angeles was january
1995.
i came out here and stayed with my
friend's older cousin
who just signed a huge record contract
with warner brothers records
for his band sister whiskey okay
good name for a band yeah it was like
you love sisters you love whiskey yeah
it was a good man
they were like a rock and roll band
almost like a poison okay a good time
rock and roll band
it was like the mid 90s it was like it
was still very much that was very much
like getting airplay and things like
that
sure and uh one of that guy's friends
was house-sitting for a porn producer
a famous porn producer named bruce seven
you could look him up it's a real guy i
think he's passed on now because i
recently looked this up because i
remembered it and i was like
i wonder if and i remember remember
bruce seven so the guy's cat sitting
so he goes it is dude he's long hair
rocker like ripped pants
he walked around he's one of those guys
never wore shoes or socks right he's
like yeah
he said come by the house he's like i'm
pouring he's like i'm house sitting for
this guy
you know bruce seven and it was like in
the valley or the hill or whatever
so we go and it's a beautiful house
he opens the front door there's a big
big like um
set of uh shelves and at that time it
was vhs still
okay no joke dude there was thousands of
porn vhs's
cat of his that he made this producer
catalogued in alphabetical order on the
wall like
like like five five shelves double wide
right and all his awards from the avians
were all on the show gorgeous house
very nice house yeah it was not like a
mansion but it was a very nice house
so we go and he's like yeah just come in
it was sitting he goes check this out
so he goes we'll get to that
there he goes he goes check this out you
want something cool and he takes us
into the uh down the hall and he opens
up a room and it's like a big big like
walk-in closet
and it's just dildos vibrators
whips outfits chests of
feathers or just all this wow porn stuff
but
plugs this uh everything in there and
we're like oh my god
he's like yeah he's like he goes the
other job i do
he starts watching the cats he's like i
clean all the dildos
he's like and i'm the guy speaking of
because that's when we think of
colleagues goes
i'm the guy that if they need anything
and you see like a hand come in
that's my hand wow he has gloves and
so so we so then we go and we're sitting
in the guy's living room we're sitting
on the couch
and he go and we're like wow that's
crazy he goes he goes yeah he goes
you want to see one of them so we're
like yeah he throws in a tape right
and he hits play and we're all sitting
there it's like five of us and we're
sitting there like oh wow
and all of a sudden these people are
having sex on the couch they're where
you're sitting on
that's hilarious it's a big self-made
metal
steel metal contraption that looked like
a a
in the living room with swings like a
swing a sex swing in it
and they would go and tie them and use
this contraption and we were like look
at this thing and then that's why we're
like wait did they have did they do that
in here and he goes
watch this and they're on the couch
you're like oh my god
and then he a hand came in with oil he
goes that's my head
let's get him as the first guest on the
podcast just
that's crazy do you think do you think
you could if i put
like i put your penis in a picture of
30 other penises flaccid penises you
could guess which penis and balls were
yours
i have to admit i i have to
like usual suspects yeah i have to
imagine
no a 30 i mean i'm not going to tell i
mean maybe
it was 20 000 but like 30 people i'm not
gonna
i mean i've been looking at it my whole
life i don't know if you could man it's
very difficult
to know which one because they all kind
of look the same yeah the penis and
balls kind of look the same
on you know you you think that you might
have trouble
i don't know i mean unless you had like
a botched circumcision i think it's
tough
yeah i don't know but i i could be wrong
i could
i just thought i just thought you know
by the way and you mentioned quickly
butt plugs what is i said plugs
do you see plugs i said plugs oh i think
it said butt plugs well i was inferring
that i just left the butt out
but what what is what like what i guess
i don't understand
because i understand what that does i
get that the blood flow thing
but what is a butt plug doing for you
it's unclear
does anybody know because people the
butt is it just
something there is something stimulating
i don't know
i guess maybe that's what it is because
if you go further enough into the butt
you can massage
a man's prostate which i guess
feels good wait but you mean when you
say
you mean like like medically yeah no no
i think the
pr it says it hits the p spot which i
assume is process which is the prostate
oh i didn't know that yeah like if you
want to go donate sperm
and you don't want to masturbate a nurse
can go in and just put her fingers
up your butt and hit your prostate and
you'll shoot sperm out of your penis
that's not true please is that true
yes i donated
the penis i've donated sperm once and
the nurse came in she said would you
like
you're kidding come on now come on she
said come on she said to me would you
like
to watch um we have pornographic film
here she said or i can come in and
stimulate a prostate which would you
like i said both
um i'm kidding no i'm kidding but i did
donate sperm
and that that's what happened but i
don't eat sperm
i don't know ten years ago for what i
was like a senior in college
no no i must have not i was a senior in
graduate school for what reason
cash yeah i got 150 bucks and
i don't know i just uh donated it
i thought well i think well the reason
why
the reason why i initially is because my
last year of graduate school
i forgot what it was like there was
something
somebody was talking about like a
shortage of sperm
or people like in something with in
vitro or whatever so me and another one
of my classmates we just went we donated
our sperm but i specifically signed
paperwork to say at that point
it's a little i guess like sometimes i
think about i'm like i wonder whatever
happened with that
but i said i didn't want you you legally
they know like you know my race
you know uh uh you know ethnicity eye
color high
education level all those things that's
known
because like you know you have to tell a
woman that but not my name or
information
so so i very well could have a child out
there
from my sperm that maybe one day i'll
run into
that's unbelievable yeah but you know
now people are finding both criminals
and relatives
with all the 23andme stuff because
they'll tell you this person is your
relative because the dna matches
wow so you might get a knock maybe one
day
all right yeah i don't know by the way
the prostate's called the male g-spot
so it's a thing oh it is but am i right
about if you just if you just hit the
prostate is just shoot the glue right
out well yeah
yeah there's some work to it but yeah
yeah i've never heard that in my life
uh-huh
what is it about that that triggers that
i don't even understand because i think
your prostate whatever like your
male anatomy it just that's what
that's where this semen comes from i
have no clue what comes from out of
right out of your calpers gland
because i i've told you guys you don't
see like speaking of pornography then
you don't see pornography like that
yeah i don't know i don't actually mean
to uh
derail this conversation no the men's
prostate
right but when i think of a man and i
think of a real man i only think of one
person i just want to say just shout out
to tom brady
for uh him and the bucks won the super
bowl they did uh
and and it was in tampa and this guy's
43 years of age
guy in the super bowl i just want to
give a little shout out to him shout out
to him and i would be
remiss to say if we didn't also
congratulate patrick mahomes
uh kansas city chiefs what an arm what a
future
those guys both may be in los angeles
right now they could absol
i mean la's the town they could be right
here in l.a
absolutely at this at this moment
i was going to start to sing from this
kelly clarkson
i don't know who sings that did i ever
tell you about the time
that i found myself in london at at a
brunch
the brunch of like a very very very very
extremely
wealthy family's home no and i walked in
there was only like
10 people there maybe 15 10 15 people
there like literally
like type of thing where like there was
caviar on the table oh my god
like i self serve right all right liv
tyler was there liam one of the the
ones dylan mcdermott the guy from oasis
one of the brothers one of the two the
one that's not traditionally known to be
mean
yeah i think liam liam woody harrison
owen wilson did i ever tell you about
this no and
i and i just walked in and they were
there and i ended up having brunch with
them and then
there was a with woody harrelson yes and
there was a there was a panic room
no in the house because these people
were so i mean dude there was there's a
panic room in the house
and we went down to the panic room and
this has been hey babe
ah yeah
damn
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey
you